[Music]
so a couple things
like just in
general you have to be very careful
about a salad bar approach to your your
training because your picking and
choosing is going to be go reine there's
just no way okay
you're you just don't do that okay it's
very modern you know we talk about the
individual and you do you and you do
what's good for you and then we have all
these cautionary tals right don't commit
to that like that level but that's just
that's just weak sauce that's all that
is
okay um you're never going going to get
it that way there's no way okay if you
if you
have a belief in cautionary
tals and you're trying to protect
yourself just you could do the math
you're not going to get it this is not
for people that are trying to protect
themselves so you just can't do the
salad bar stuff you have to
you you know that that would be from a
psycho even just from a an ontological
or psychological
level okay but when you add to that the
fact that everything
is
systematic anytime you don't pick
what's there for you to adopt you just
broke the
system okay
so you might you might the reason I
mention in these two things because you
you might not uh you might not believe
in the system you see you might
believe that there's no ho to
it but even if that was the case the
first problem is big enough that you
shouldn't do it okay but here in this
case it is
systematic and everything fits together
so when you take something out
you you broke everything it just doesn't
work
okay so um some of the reasons why we
break
something is ultimately of course
because their ego reifying but one of
the ways that that ego reification takes
shape is you won't let go of old
knowledge okay you're comfortable with
old knowledge uh and you just won't let
go of it um um again I don't know if
anyone ever told you but that's just
I don't understand why you hold
on to
once you know something you
let go of it you you let go of all of it
you don't you don't
slowly open your grip and and then
tomorrow I'll try to tilt the out
of my hand you just let go of
it so you have a lot of versions of
techniques they just goofy they don't
work you should not you shouldn't do
them you should come with pure eyes to
see what is the system and then you
duplicate the system but if you hold on
to old knowledge it filters what I'm
showing you and you don't see what I'm
showing you you you only see what you
already know which you should not know
you should have never known in the first
place
okay um and because this is the ultimate
source if you if I'm making video and
you can't see what I'm doing cuz you saw
something else there's no point there's
no
point so take more seriously whether you
can actually see what I'm
doing or whether you
can't and I would start from the very
simple point of view is I am not doing
what you were
doing I am not doing what your teacher
does there there's not one technique
that I do that I've ever seen anyone
else do ever it is always different and
when you get down to it it's different
at a core level it's not a variation one
is TR and one is false one works and one
does not work okay so learn to see what
I'm putting out there problematize
whether you can see or not that's the
beginning of dashy Hood
okay all right so we did a video I'm
going to explain this one more to help
you see the difference in what I was
doing okay we did a video the qu the
question that sparked the video is
where's the opening for Shon nag okay so
that's that's the question
again somebody's trying to fight with
the Kon I don't try to fight with the
Keyon but I can entertain this question
from a tactical architectural point of
you that's what we're doing okay so what
tends to
happen in the opening of shon Naga and
in the video what I did is if you go
into the front Inward
kazushi and he is able to extend my
circle then he will come back on the
other side of that Circle and that is
the opening for sh net okay so for
example if I am trying to
do this C nogget that's the front inward
kazushi is that you guys see that okay
that that's what the first thing so I
tried to do the front inward kazushi
okay so he tries to do the front Inward
kazushi and this leg comes around like
that do you see he's not going to go
into the front inward kazushi he
extended my
circle and he is now open for shho nin
okay it doesn't look like that it it
it's very gross and ugly and there's a
lot of stumbling because we're going to
project that foot do you know what I
mean so like if I'm coming in and he's
going he's he's trying to get me off of
that foot do you see
that so as we're going and you s it this
might look like that do you see all the
same thing happened
okay so I'm trying to do that he extends
around it and there's the opening for sh
it's right there okay so what is
required his
energy has to be
going uh in an extension of the front
inward kazushi pattern
okay so he can't be going the other way
it's not going to be there here's where
it's now
artificial that's not going to happen
that's that's not the Tactical opening
okay or we're here and he changes level
and he comes underneath this isn't where
you're going to do sh Naga either that's
artificial what's going to happen he's
coming in he extends
past there inertia is going this way
okay and his
stance is
offset to my positioning okay so what I
mean by that say
is from a certain point of
view his feet are
square do you see that but from another
angle they're not
Square so the angle that I'm in is not
here that would be square feet okay
I'm
on this this angle more over here and
the way you can tell what's going on is
that the leg is easily
sweepable okay so let's
say he's coming around and you can find
this sweep very easily
okay but that would be close range
grappling I'd have to be close enough to
do that in other words if if I'm out
here that's I you you seeo people do
that all the time but that that's
you get a one to one step so if
I'm here and I go there
right that would be fine okay and in a
way that's sh n okay
what happens in
Shon is that I'm out at
midrange midrange I can't reach the foot
without taking two steps to get there
okay so at
mid-range that's the that's the first
thing okay I'm going to let them play
with that and then we'll build up more
so careful cuz even here I saw you guys
doing something different okay so it's
the front inward kazushi
okay uh and so if he if he was trying to
do the front inward kazushi you can see
my hat you see the Tilt in my body you
see and so when this comes around notice
where my head
is he's not just turning
me and I'm standing perfectly straight
if that's not the opening
okay uh
so usually when it comes out for me is
either Ronin or Tristan they're very
athletic and we're doing a guaza and
they're count they countered the caga
you see but they lost enough balance
that gives the opening okay for the Shon
nag so it's not that I'm on
balance this this this is not it cuz
we're pretty even do you see
that this is it do you see that is very
different that's the opening okay and it
might be depending on their athleticism
their head might even be
lower okay because they you're trying to
throw them harder they have to reconcile
more of the angles of cancellation the
head is lower and the body is more
tilted make sense okay so if you're
you're training this and you're trying
to go slow to get yourself familiar with
the
mechanics I would come around this way
and you're you're here like that okay
down here
not not
walking around that's that's not it you
should feel that person's not in kazushi
you need to need to let go draw a weapon
or something else
okay all right so um let's look at the
energy so his
inertia is going that way do you
see so let me show you how we got how we
how I did that okay it's on this hand so
this hand that's going around I feel him
counter it do you see okay and when I I
bring this to
me it will generate the centrifugal
energy more and make him go more into
the Tilt okay I do not try to turn his
hand he's turning my hand just comes
straight into me okay so I go around War
I feel him my hand just goes into me
because his
inertia is circular
it does what I need it to do
okay on the other
side and I'm trying for this one that's
it that's all I'm doing
okay boom that's
it okay and you can see that it lowers
his head it already has the fall and is
continuing the kazushi okay so let's try
that one now detail I'm correcting my
folks here so as you you come around
like that you don't want to bring him
around like this okay you
continuing the energy that he's going
here do you see
that so you're not going to make him do
something like
this no we're not we're not going to do
that
okay he came here boom he countered take
that energy that and that keeps him
going around me okay got it so if you're
the
UK it's a little scary because you're a
constant kazushi so again don't push so
hard he goes you come around and you
should be going this
way
okay so the guy came in I attempted to
tilt him he came around I even going
around makees sense we'll do it one more
time the guy came in I tilted him he
extended the circle I keep him going on
that New Path okay so if you look at
him just look down he got tilted and his
Energy's coming around
okay I don't want to
be where he's going to hit me okay I
don't want to move him behind
me and now he is behind me this does not
make sense okay
so like all
likeo as he's making a circle this way I
make a circle this way you see that okay
so he's going
around I go here okay
I go okay and as he came around I'm not
facing him does that make sense so again
it's not that I'm here I do all that he
stops and then I go we're in motion
okay so he's going around
I okay let's try started with
problematize whether you can see what
I'm doing or not okay and
so here's where you're going and even
some of our people here is they come
around like this and then they enter and
they're like that well he's not he's
over there I didn't turn he's turning I
don't need to turn Okay so as I come
around this way he goes that way I'm
here I'm here and I go like that I don't
enter and turn he's over there and I
don't want that okay
that's the first thing he's turning I
don't need to turn he's turning around
me I don't need to turn if I
turn and he's turning around me I'm
going to overturn okay and that means
I'm going to take him out of the kazushi
pattern that he is in so I'll show you
what that means so I'm going around here
right and then I'm trying to stop I'm
trying to stop him you see that okay and
that's not that's not the
art
instead he's going around
and I go here all right okay so not not
I don't I'm not doing this sh
yet let alone worse very common very
very common okay I take them around this
way then I do
Ur well I'd be running into him you see
that so he's going around and then boom
like that's just dumb okay that's dumb
why did you do that well we're supposed
to have a
ER
why why it's
stupid cuz some ferite told you and you
need that belt give me a break how about
you need the skill and you don't do
stupid things okay so pay attention cuz
this is where it gets different I go
right here
into the
throw one more time just looking at the
entry boom boom it's right
there there's no more rotation on me he
rotated boom
boom and if you look at him he has one
kazushi
pter okay I don't reverse him I don't
stop him
okay where we end up is a little
different I'll explain that in the next
break but let's work on this do not
turn let him put his arm into
shag okay do your best let's try it okay
so he's going
around and let's do this
side when I bring my hand in it makes
him keep going going around you
see so his inertia is going that way
right we know that okay now as he go as
he's going around and I bring his hand
up it is actually keeping him going that
way you get that okay so now I if you
watch that with that in mind we're going
to go really slow okay I'm timing as
he's going around I have to follow the
rule that this has to happen on my wuji
line do you see that but I'm not going
to enter cuz now I have to turn do you
see that I've entered on the turn
boom one more time from
here he's going around right I'm not
going here and
here I'm keeping the energy his energy
is going like
that and I'm keeping the energy with his
arm
here you guys see that okay so watch for
that now you come
around not here here just here
this makes the arm tight watch this I go
here I enter the arm is loose it's loose
until
here this arm is tight
TI
okay so you can feel for that tension
too w
okay we'll do a kaga there just
accelerate more his centrifugal energy
try right this is the last
Point remember that his head is going to
tilt and his head is going to lower he
is in check he's in kazushi there's
angles of cancellation cutting through
his body you never uncheck him his head
cannot gain height okay right now
everything we're doing to show these
principles is is allowing his head to
gain height but that's not the technique
okay so if you if we look at his
head you plot it how far is it from the
mat okay his head is down here it stays
down there I don't let it come back up
okay now the problem happens when you
lift the
hand you see so you have to lower you
you lower you so you don't lift the hand
so his head doesn't come back up
okay so I'm going do kind of
slow and I'm
here
okay if you ever
felt this you should get the hell out of
there that's going to work
okay or if you ever feel him stop that's
not going to work either you should get
the hell out of
it what you're feeling instead is the
extension than
the doing the
technique if you try to turn like the
way everyone else that she so you in
turn he's going to be gone by the time
that happens okay so the step that I
take into the throat is immediately
going
down I'm not pulling him down with the
Descent of my
body
meaning I don't go here I'm up and then
I drop because it's head
K my Center starts to drop
immediately can you see
that e